- Chiropractor where you
hold your stress. (laughing)
Facts! Facts on facts on facts.
By the way, there's no way
that those are the actual shoulders.
I think there's some kind of device there.
We turtle like this as
humans, and as a result,
a lot of people have very tight
cervical paraspinal muscles
as well as their traps.
If this goes on for a
very long period of time,
we see chronic changes in the spine there.
Well, this person's taking
a dirty fork to the patella.
Looks like to the quad tendon.
Don't know why.
Oh, my God! Wait, what?
This isn't a human leg being opened,
because I've opened humans' cadavers
and this is not what they look like.
They're not chalky on the inside.
- Here is this week's exercise
to keep your brain nimble
and build those superhighways.
- Well, that's true.
The brain does actually build
superhighways when you use it.
- Pinky. Finger.
Switch 'em. Switch 'em.
Switch 'em. Switch 'em one more time.
- That's cool, but, like,
you can just do activities
that have a little bit
more meaning than this.
"Saw this kid doing a
workout incorrectly."
Yeah, I mean, not perfect
form, but not terrible either.
I've seen that machine be
misused so many different ways.
(laughing) Like that.
Okay, I do not know where this is going.
Is this a Halloween costume? Well, okay.
This is a family-friendly channel.
Wait, she's taking selfies like this?
Why is there other things inside the lips?
It could be just a Halloween
costume and we're judging it.
If it's for any kind of medical utility,
the answer is pretty
much no, unless it's for,
like, some kind of
endoscopy, upper endoscopy.
Then I'm speaking outside
of my own comfort zone.
- Did you know that rubbing
your fingernails together
like this daily stimulates the brain
to send signals to adult stem cells?
- Or it creates paronychia. (laughs)
And paronychia are quite painful.
Check them out.
- [Computerized Voice]
When I come home from work
and use my neck stretcher.
- I've seen this thing on TikTok
and it looks so ridiculous.
I can't imagine that it does anything.
But I probably should try
it once before I knock it.
Just don't make any claims.
- Oh.
- Okay, it makes a guy
moan when he comes home.
I'm okay with that claim.
- Nice.
- "Going to bed drunk be like..."
Oh, yeah, the spins, baby!
It actually can be quite dangerous
if you are not awake enough to puke
that you can end up having
some of the vomit aspirate
into your lungs and cause
infection and inflammation.
When people say someone died
of an overdose, a lot of times,
it's through this,
aspirating their own vomit.
- I'm gonna show you how
to reset your nervous
system in 30 seconds.
- Wow. Oh, my God.
It's like we're Windows PC.
- Put out your thumb,
put out your other thumb
and your pointer finger,
and then you're going
to apply pressure for
20 seconds like this,
and it really works.
- It really doesn't!
There's ways to actually stimulate one
of the main nerves in your body
that is responsible for
parasympathetic tone,
and that's your vagus nerve
because it innervates your diaphragm.
So if you're able to
go into deep breathing,
that can actually change the
way your body's functioning
with its parasympathetic drive.
That works.
- We're playing everyone's
favorite game this morning.
You know it!
You love it!
Let's say the title
together: "Do I Feel This Way
Because of the New Prescription
I Just Started Taking
or Because I Ran Out of My
Other Two Prescriptions?"
- Oh, that's a problematic game.
- Here's a little hint.
The winner is not me.
- Especially if you're not on
some mental health medications
that if you come off abruptly,
you can go into withdrawal.
That can change how you feel
very quickly, very uncomfortably.
- The German inventor Rebecca Weiss
has invented the testicle bath,
which uses ultrasound technology
to temporarily stop sperm mobility.
- Oh, my God.
You know, it's funny.
In med school, there was always a joke
that if you spend X number of minutes
in a hot tub with this temperature,
you lose the ability to be fertile
for that short period of time,
and everyone made a joke
like "Oh, I'm gonna do that
instead of using a condom," and no!
It's silly and not accurate
and we shouldn't do it.
- The best part is it
only needs to be used once
every couple months in
order to prevent pregnancy.
- Mmm, yeah, I don't know about that.
I need to see the evidence
before I start talking
about bathing testicles for birth control.
- All right, guys, let's
talk about Natalia Dyer
from "Stranger Things."
So if I was Natalia's injector,
this is what I would do.
- Are we really judging their face
and then saying what we're
going to do to their face?
I mean, this is messed up.
Like, you're basically
saying everything wrong
with this person's face.
Like, talk about giving someone a complex.
I have a feeling, after seeing this video,
this person's gonna go on and
do the same thing about me
and be like, "His face is unsalvageable."
- All right, let's see what the
final product would give us.
- Oh, did she Facetune her?
- Ta-da! All right, how do
we like my Photoshop skills?
- They (beep)!
When you go see a plastic surgeon,
there should be a conversation
about body dysmorphia
before you undergo certain things.
But it seems like this provider
is just pushing treatment
on people who don't even want it.
- [Computerized Voice]
Somebody lose their dog?
- Oh, my God.
That does look like my dog.
Bear, come here!
You have a friend here.
I heard you're supposed to make them aware
of your surroundings.
Like, if this was a
black bear, I would say,
"Hi, black bear. Come up."
I'm aware of my surroundings.
Please don't lick my face.
Are you a black bear or brown bear?
Your breath smells like fish.
Oh, my God, is that a
chest compressions kit?
Oh, my God, I need to see it.
Is it good?
Yo, those are good chest compressions.
Yo, those are two inches
deep. Good rhythm.
That's better than a
human can probably do.
But I will say, where that
machine probably won't work
is 99% of all chest compression times
when you need to chest compress,
because chest compressions happen at home,
on the street, where you find people down,
and that's where hands-only
CPR really needs to happen.
And guess what?
Most people aren't carrying
that in their back pocket.
A baby getting a Q-Tip?
Better not be going in the ear.
What? Okay.
What did I just witness here?
That was the freakiest thing ever.
Okay, that doesn't happen.
Just saying, this is not a natural reflex.
There are all sorts of
reflexes that babies do
which are actually kind of adorable.
If you've ever seen,
like, the startle reflex,
if you were to fake drop
a baby, the baby, like,
naturally reaches out to
try and save themselves.
We check these things.
- "@robmcelhenney Can you please tell me
how in the hell you got so ripped?
Putting us all into shame
after that transformation."
What you're gonna need to do
is, you have a chef, right?
Like, a personal chef.
So make sure the chef, uh, makes
you a lot of chicken breast
and make sure you keep your caloric intake
at a certain level, and as
you go to your physician
two to three times a week
just to monitor all your
testosterone levels-
- You don't need to see your doctor
multiple times a week to check anything
unless you actively
have a serious problem.
I can't remember the last
time I needed to see a patient
multiple times in a week.
You also don't need to swear off food.
But yeah, I get what he's saying.
Like, to get an extreme look in your body
will take extreme steps, and
that's not always healthy.
We look at people who
have ripped six-packs
and we assume that
they're extremely healthy.
That's not always the case.
Sometimes that comes at the
cost of their mental health,
which makes it tremendously unhealthy.
Okay? A little adductor
work never hurt nobody.
Adductors are commonly
strained with exercise,
so you do need to strengthen
them and stretch them.
I don't know why it
needs to be in this room
and in this position and in this outfit,
but to each their own.
- So when I first lost my leg,
it was absolutely mind-blowing to me
how hungry I was every
second of every day,
especially when I started
using my prosthetic,
learning how to walk again.
- Well, you definitely
will be using more energy
to adapt in the short term.
Also, if you just got out of a surgery,
you're also gonna need
more calories to heal
because that's a metabolic
demand on your body.
- Especially as an amputee with the gift
of being pretty mobile and pretty active,
I am hungry all of the time.
- If a patient is overly
hungry all of the time,
like, a year or two post-surgery,
that is a potential reason
to do a further work-up.
You know, we're talking
about thyroid levels,
cholesterol levels,
sugar levels, et cetera.
Because there are conditions
that can present themselves
with feeling hungry all the time.
- [Nathaniel] This is day 292 of walking
on all fours every day.
- Our bodies weren't made for this,
so you're gonna have extreme,
extreme agony in your low back.
The length of your arms,
length of your legs,
the muscle position,
the muscles' insertions,
the spinal cord, it's not
meant for this type of walking.
We're meant to walk upright.
So while this could be a cool exercise,
I wouldn't recommend this.
- Next time you eat, pay attention
if your nose starts to run.
- Your nose can start to run
if you're having an allergic reaction,
if you're experiencing a viral illness,
if you get increased circulation
to your nasal mucosa.
- If you're eating and your
nose starts to run, stop eating.
If I eat something that's not
good for me, my nose runs.
- If I right now have a
little bit of spicy sauce,
my nose is gonna run.
Spicy sauce is not
necessarily bad for you,
and if I had a tiny bit of it,
that also doesn't mean I'm full.
So your thing just got debunked
on face value, sorry to say.
- What color were my eyes...
- Oh, wow.
I've heard of this. Depositing ink.
Medical intervention, even if
it's for cosmetic purposes,
should be eliminated at all costs.
So many things can go
wrong, and then good luck
figuring out if you have a
medical condition after that.
And again, like, I want
you to express yourself,
but I want you to express yourself
without putting yourself at risk.
Okay, this is the weirdest
thing I've ever seen.
If anyone sends me this to the P.O. box
that I have listed in my
description down below,
I will be very shocked.
- You're looking at the face of someone
who hasn't eaten cooked
food in almost five years.
Cooked food is a compromise.
It makes us sick and we don't know it.
- No. My guy.
I've seen patients in hospital settings
where they can't cook their foods,
and they have horrible illnesses.
They lose their lives.
Children lose their lives. Why?
Contaminated water and contaminated food
because they can't cook them.
So from all the privilege that we have
for having all these clean
foods, there's many places
in the world where clean
food's not an option.
So let's be reasonable here.
- If we just eat raw food only,
it'll reverse all of our
health issues, make us-
- Reverse them! We'll live
forever, just... (screams)
- So you know how you go to the gym?
- Yeah.
- You do your workouts.
You do your abs.
- Well, sometimes.
- It's usually in the morning,
middle of the day, whatever.
- Well, I usually do it at night.
- You're doing it wrong.
- Why?
- Guys, do your abs before bed.
- I do do that. But why?
- For eight hours, when you sleep,
you don't drink, you don't eat,
meaning your stomach does not expand,
so those muscles you just
worked on work 10 times better
than when you usually just
eat right after a workout.
- Okay, the logic is
that because your stomach
is not expanding, your abdominal muscles,
which are separate from your
stomach muscles, stay flat.
How does that mean that they work harder?
Once you stop doing the abdominal workout,
the repair begins.
It doesn't matter what's
going on in your stomach.
And doing abs has nothing to do with fat.
Just putting that out there as well.
- I work in supplement industry,
and I see a lot of companies
actually make up terms
to sound legit so you can pay more,
but those terms actually have no meanings.
- Yeah, that's literally everything.
Everything in the supplement
industry does not need
to be proven, unless they make a claim
and then they actually hurt somebody.
Then the FDA starts to
step in and act on it.
Actually, I don't think it's even the FDA.
I think the FTC starts acts on it.
- First, if they say they are tested
by FDA-approved laboratory,
don't believe them,
because FDA does not
approve any laboratories.
- What? No.
What they say is an FDA-approved facility
where other things are made,
like when we did our bad
doctor thing, we said...
It's an FDA-approved building
and there's a rental space next door.
- Second, if they say they
are third-party tested
without telling you which third party,
chances they are not third-party tested.
- Or they're tested but the
third party is their bro.
- "Contains clinically
tested ingredients."
- All ingredients in life
pretty much have been clinically tested.
That means nothing.
Those are just words.
- Last, if they say they
are pharmaceutical grade-
- That's the best, when they start
calling their supplements nutraceuticals
because they're like, "It's, like,
almost pharmaceutical, our supplements."
If you sell supplements only to doctors,
you're doing it strictly to
give yourself that label,
not because there's any restriction
for you to sell them
general to the public.
- [Speaker] When you forget
to change your socks.
- Oh, my...
- Pewoo!
- Oh, no.
Okay, so do you know that
your feet prune as a way
to give you better stability
inside a moist environment?
It's not just, like, a physical response.
It's an actual neurological response.
- [Speaker] Oh, my God, bro.
- There's also probably
a fungal component there
if you don't change
your socks in the field,
because that's gonna
trap moisture, darkness,
all that stuff that creates
a good housing environment
for the fungi in your life.
- This is to anyone
thinking of getting freckles
tattooed on their face.
- Wow.
- Don't.
- It's interesting.
People without freckles get
freckles tattooed on them.
People with freckles
pay for miracle serums
to remove the freckles.
The grass isn't greener.
I'm telling you this.
- So they call this the
one-minute health check.
All you gotta do is
take a spoon and rub it
all over your tongue.
- Don't tell me.
- And then place it under
some light for about a minute.
And you're technically healthy
if you pick back up the spoon
and it's clean, no
blotches or odor. (sniffs)
But if it does smell kind of sharp,
there could be an issue with your stomach.
- Hold up. Wait a minute.
- People look to you and
they trust your content,
and then you make stuff like this,
which is just so obviously wrong.
I can't watch this.
- All hail Dr. Spoon.
- No. No, no hail Dr. Spoon.
Maybe that was comedy
and I'm judging it
harshly for no reason, so.
I reserve because I don't
know what happens on TikTok.
But clearly misinformation there,
and I hope it gets
demonetized, taken down,
whatever they do on TikTok.
Look, as you can see with so many TikToks,
you've gotta be really careful online.
It's so important you
don't just blindly trust
random medical advice videos.
You need to be able to think
for yourself and verify
when information is coming
from a reliable source.
That's why I'm actually
so excited to talk to you
about the sponsor of
today's video, Brilliant,
a learning tool that will help you expand
not just your knowledge but your ability
to understand the world
around you as a whole.
Brilliant has thousands of lessons
with exclusive new content added monthly
on fascinating subjects like astrophysics,
programming with Python, and
my favorite, logic problems,
many of which are actually designed
to help you identify liars,
which would certainly come in handy
when trying to identify
misinformation online.
Look, when my patients come to me
to develop a healthy
lifestyle, I always make sure
that they know long-term, consistent,
and manageable behavior changes
are what's gonna give them
long-term results that
they're looking for.
The same goes for your brain,
and by just spending a few minutes a day
on Brilliant studying something new,
it's gonna really benefit your mind
for the rest of your life.
To get started for free,
brilliant.org/doctormike,
remember, doctor is spelled out,
and click the link in the description.
The first 200 of you will get 20% off
of Brilliant's annual
premium subscription.
Draw My Life videos!
They're back, baby!
Here's my story coming to
America. Full animation.
Very fun. Check it out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)